I'm not the Mike Fred Rogers in any way
shape or form except I think I wake up
in the morning thinking like hey it's a
nice day that's a good day let's try to
make it a little bit better so good to
see you again today
the transformation into mr. Rogers is
remarkable
so was co-star Matthew Reese's
experience of working with Tom what is
it like playing opposite someone who is
the nicest person well and having to
stare into that face I want to know hang
on what did you tell Reese plays the
journalist whose life is forever change
after interviewing mr. Rogers of course
he made a name for himself as a ruthless
Russian spy with his Emmy winning role
in the Americans you get the prints I'll
get the car his co-star turned longtime
love Keri Russell couldn't have looked
prouder
at the film's premiere you guys fell in
love at the time you playing traitors to
the American cause yes pretending to be
somebody that you're not
yes the Welsh actor told me his son Sam
helped prepare him for this role we
didn't have mr. Rogers growing up but I
have a three and half year old son who
became Mike could have conduit we sing
the song often in the house it's a
beautiful day in this neighborhood did I
just hear you singing by the way on the
other side of the spontaneous yes it's a
good feeling to know you're alive it's
such a happy feeling I think I make us
happy a beautiful day in the
neighborhood hits theaters today
[Music]